Eric thanks for joining us we appreciate
your time let me start with Jerry Jones
with 18 game regular season not the
first time we've heard this but how does
the NFL Players Association react to
this definitely not the the first time
we've heard this and I don't think our
position has changed I don't have any
guys coming up to me saying you know
they're okay can you really say really
make more games happen for us you know
we just don't we're not playing enough
right now so that's the way I look at it
you know these guys don't see the
positive trade offs the guys don't see
it as something that is good for their
career is good for their bodies you know
et cetera I'm so much has been already
written on it and and and said about it
I don't I don't see and I haven't heard
anything that's that changes that well I
guess I'm wondering if you have a lot of
these players who are role players
secondary players if they know that they
can make $500,000 extra with these two
games you know wouldn't they wouldn't
the majority of players want to sign up
where your marquee players probably
wouldn't want to add two more games to
the regular season yeah but that's not
in actuality what would happen a there
there wouldn't be that much more money
to be spread around that what that would
increase every player's by 500,000 on
average and to you know that money would
go into the cap and as you know and as
we know that cap is going to get tilted
heavily towards the star player so some
of your star players would make more but
you're all players and my in my view and
then the way I've looked at it and
everything I've read and the people that
I've talked about even with GM's
on how that money could be spread
wouldn't go to your world players
wouldn't go to your guys your
middle-of-the-road guys what you're
talking about
Jerry Jones also said that there was
data that backed up his claim that
there's more concussions and uptick in
concussions during the preseason as
opposed to the regular season have you
seen this data Jerry Jones talked about
that and I do we have the exact wording
on that mclovin just to be fair to Jerry
Jones yeah he said there's a study if
they eliminate two preseason games and
add two regular-season games
it will actually added health B's or
more injuries or imprecision seaton do
you have this sound so I can play it for
Eric here so Jerry Jones my solution is
real simple is cut back on preseason
games have one at each team's home play
a couple of them and then you need to
add two games to the regular season
which I've been a proponent of for
several years it's probably physically
better for players than it is to have
the longer preseason the longer
practicing our studies showed that we
actually have a ramped up injury
situation with players during preseason
have you seen this data yet yet yet lies
damned lies and statistics right you
know it listen what he's referring to I
believe and this is the this is the data
I've seen is what he's referring to is a
heightened concussion rate or heightened
injury rate in the preseason because you
have 90 guys on a roster in the
preseason some of them which are they're
the first time in their NFL life they
don't know what they're doing
obviously indecision leads to injury and
then in the regular season you have
practices in which you only hit once a
week during this season right now you're
hitting six times a week so of course
you could say oh well there's more
injury rate there's an INT there's a
greater injury occurrence and the
preseason then there isn't the regular
season we all know that's not really how
you would read the data if you were sort
of being honest about it let's face it
and and how and how that ends up shaking
out so I mean let's just look at it from
a common-sense standpoint does does
anybody think playing more get to more
games it's safer for players know though
to act like playing to more games it's
safer for players is it's just to me a
pretty silly comment we're talking to
Eric Winston he's the president of the
NFL Players Association where do we
stand with the anthem feels like it's
kind of quiet on both sides here what's
gonna happen opening weekend
you know yeah I don't know I don't I
don't go out and tell guys you know you
have to do this or you have to do that I
think that's you know they they make
their decisions I can tell you right now
that that the two sides have been
talking we've been talking about a
resolution around this issue and we've
been talking about you know making sure
that the guys especially the guys that
have protested have a forum so they can
they can come in and directly speak to
some of us ownership about what exactly
they're trying to do and I think a lot
of guys are looking to move from from
where they've been to action now they
want something or they want to make it
substantive they want to make it lasting
and I applaud that because I think at
the end of the day that's what our guys
have always been about is really making
some sense of changes in the
neighborhood's they've grew up growing
up in and the society that they see
around so we're still talking about it
we're still trying to figure out exactly
what it looks like but I can but I think
as you said things have been quiet
because we have been talking we've been
trying to give ourselves the distance to
make sure that when we come to some sort
of resolution it is lasting and that
it's meaningful isn't this more team by
team Eric than it is the overall
perspective of the NFL or the Players
Association that it's the owner dealing
with his team dealing with his local
market it's just that you want to
appease your fan base there that the
owner is you know Jerry Jones is only
worried about dak Prescott in Ezekiel
Elliott standing for the anthem he wants
his star player he wants everybody
standing here I don't think he's as
concerned about the rest of the league
as he is how does this come off to my
fan base Jacksonville has it come off to
that fan base so it feels like it's more
you know team by team of how these
owners are approaching this can only
affect their their team their locales
but I will tell you that a lot of
ownership feels that that football is
not view that way that it's a national
game that were we're a national pastime
now and we're America's top sports so we
also you can also say that hey fan bases
if you're in New York you watch the
Monday night game between the Chargers
and the Raiders or whomever is playing
and
as you have in other sports you have
where it's a very local sport like
you're talking about now obviously
ownership can only affect that but I
would tell you that ownership is it's
concerned with what's going around the
league and that ex-owner in one locale
is worried about what's going on in
other locales even though they might be
able to only affect their team I would
say they're worried about what's going
on throughout the league and I
understand that but at the same time
like I said these guys are trying to
effectuate some positive change in their
neighborhoods and in the society as I
see and so you know we're facilitating a
lot of these discussions and like I said
I'm still hopeful Erika thank you we
appreciate your time thanks for joining
us all right on it's Eric Winston he's
the NFL Players Association for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]